imagine you get sent day in and day out
to a random company to work without pay
each workday starts with an hour-long
meeting followed by another meeting and
another meeting and so on and so forth
all meetings are on different seemingly
random corporate objectives focus on X
improve why remember Zed
your primary job sit down shut up listen
to your supervisor and take note
and when you think that the day is
finally over you are told to take some
of the work home
sounds like a horrific Corporation
doesn't it this however is the perceived
reality of many young people in what's
called a 21st century school so how did
we happen to end up here
[Music]
Frederick the great the King of Prussia
came up with the idea of modern Factory
schools the emperor was inspired by
Plato who argued that the ideal city
requires ideal individuals and ideal
individuals requiring ideal education
and so the king introduced compulsory
education in 1763 with the mission to
unify Germany increase literacy and
boost the education of all its citizens
including the very poor
the early Prussian school system
provided eight years of instruction in
Reading Writing music and religious
studies it imposed a strict ethos of
Duty discipline and obedience and that
worked
the model turned into a big cultural
economical and Military success that
inspired rulers from Tokyo to Washington
not long after State officials all
around the world started writing
curriculums and public education became
both a child's right and Duty
in 1938 the Germans then went one step
further and made School attendance
compulsory ever since it's not parents
but the state that makes sure kids go to
school
today 85 percent out of all adults
worldwide illiterate and access to
information is abundant should
government officials still have a
monopoly on how we learn a growing
number of parents don't think so and
want to take control over their own
child's education they advocate for
what's called unschooling
unschooling is the process of learning
through life outside institutionalized
classrooms similar to homeschooling it
usually happens at home or in other
places but while homeschooling usually
follows a formal curriculum unschooling
doesn't
unschoolers learn through their natural
life experiences including play chores
travel books elective classes board
games internships mentors and living in
a community
parents or tutors play a big role they
provide resources facilitate the
learning experiences and help the child
to reflect on their progress
so how come parents choose to one school
their children when it's much more
convenient to send them to school there
are six key reasons
schools can negatively affect the
parent-child relationship often
replacing it with an atmosphere of fear
[Music]
institutionalizing kids in a
one-size-fits-all classroom is an
inefficient use of their time and
potential because it requires each one
to learn a subject in a particular way
and at a pace that doesn't take into
account a child's interests or any
pre-existing knowledge they might have
in school children are primarily taught
how to follow instructions which means
they don't practice doing things
independently unschoolers have to solve
problems by themselves all the time they
learn to work autonomously
school children are told all their lives
what to do as a result they later often
have no idea what they want and hence
simply conform unschoolers practice
making their own decisions every day
they learn to know what they want and
are more likely to question social ills
School focuses almost exclusively on
what to learn all day unschoolers learn
to ask the much more important question
why learn it
schools cover only a few subjects
someone thought of a few hundred years
ago unschoolers can explore way more
interests and look into topics at far
greater depth
John Holt a pioneer of unschooling said
it as follows the anxiety children feel
are constantly being tested Their Fear
of failure punishment and disgrace
severely reduces their ability both to
perceive and to remember and drives them
away from the material being studied
into strategies for fooling teachers
into thinking they know what they really
don't know
what do you think what are the good and
bad sides of unschooling and more
broadly should the state or parents
decide what to teach a child and what to
leave out who should have the ultimate
say please share your thoughts in the
comments below
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com